it's always easy I find it I have two
kids and it is you don't need to get
them presents when they're younger yes
because you can just give them any toy
it gets more complicated as they get
older agree difficult but I'm told that
you gave was it your son when he was two
is this right you gave him Beyonce's
autograph yeah is it two year old care
about Beyonce's autograph I mean 20/20
hindsight yeah yeah I know you know
you're right I mean it and and who
really even knows if it's or you know
signature you know I mean it's an eight
by ten then you know the black sharpie
I'm sorry african-american sharpie but
but ya know in retrospect yeah we
probably should have just got him toys
yeah yeah so what I mean that's so easy
it's so easy just to go to any toy store
and get him that I know but it's so it
but you know it's what I mean yeah no
you're right you tried to you it's also
it's his second birthday he has no idea
what's going on that's true
he has no idea the significance of this
day so you could you know you could give
him you know a cookie yes and say happy
birthday and it absolutely you know
without a doubt and I could sign the
back I mean she could sign the back of
that and it would be busted busted your
kids are the intern age where they know
what it is that dad does know just does
a little bit Otis is here he's backstage
not watching television I'm sure just
we're running around crazy but um Daisy
doesn't and when and Daisy and Otis are
squabbling a lot right now because she
eats his toys she's one-and-a-half she
doesn't know any better
has no idea who Beyonce is but does but
also does but my joke with Otis is that
whenever she's doing something you know
bad or hits him I'm like you gotta take
it easy on her she's got peanut butter
for brains right now and and he loves
that he's like he's like and my theory
is and and I've done tremendous research
on Infowars about this is that is that
as she learns the the language the
English language that's our chosen
language at home is that in her brain
becomes solid matter but right now it's
just peanut butter that's that's your
term for the developmental stage that
your daughter is made of peanut butter
yeah I'm not a doctor yeah
you